so from your skype critique with pallar
I don't think she said you have to
decide ending do you want to sort of
market this to family-friendly ABC NBC
market or something with a little more
of an edge to it like an FX I wrote it
with the intention of like being more
independent more FX kind of stuff but it
feels it feels like and I was just
talking with art about this yesterday it
feels like I get this sort of pressure
to be clean more time than I understand
because it's more marketable and you you
know I don't know laps to me is
something that I'm doing with I don't
know it's it's tough it's tough
because you I never went into writing
laps with thinking that this should be
on NBC I just thought of it as a web
series and I felt that web series you
could just take chances my certain type
of style is like a mixture between clean
and then surprising you with something
that's wrong crazy and that's that sort
where I find my little joy in writing
you know and creating this stuff so
wherever that lands I yeah I know
Nickelodeon absolutely all I said I just
slime the air now yes lightly good but
because I have a family and because I'm
married it goes back to that fence thing
it's like I want to be able to get it
you know get more work off of this you
know because of them so I guess there's
that pressure you know and then there's
the other side of me if I was just
saying I will just do whatever I wanted
kind of thing so I'm keeping that in
mind can you do one for the studio
system and then 14 yeah that's what I
can
I what is it Suicide Girls or something
yeah exactly yeah right I I i don't know
i don't see i see sorry I'm just trying
to get my thoughts on right now I see
what you're talking about that he's
saying they're saying he has a family
now he wants to be able to I think part
of like you know aside from having that
influence is also the desire to create
content that you can share with your
family well I have a word of caution on
that because sometimes that doesn't work
so well um gonna name names here look at
Eddie Murphy's career recently when he
stopped being beverly hills cop and the
raw comic guy he was and he started
doing family-friendly fair yeah right
down quality went to nothing you know
because it doesn't feel like him it
doesn't feel like him and I think that
there's no reason why you need to bottle
yourself in the one thing or the other
yeah if you if you have instincts or
abilities to do some needs allege you're
a little raw a little dirty or whatever
do that too it doesn't hurt I mean
there's lots of family men who have
created both sorts of things you know
it's absolutely plausible and I told
chad i think i'd love to see him push
the envelope because i've read some of
the other stuff he's done and it it was
there but it felt like there was some
restraint and it's this exact sort of
thing it's like battle of where do i go
as a writer as a creator what do I want
to do and I don't you I guarantee
there's plenty of people who write for
family-friendly study Aaron Sorkin wrote
for networks but then Aaron Sorkin also
wrote you know things for HBO of things
for cinema you know so he can do it both
ways that sort of stuff yeah I think
it's easy for us as audience members to
point the finger and say oh they sold
out you know the indie band that was so
great they were hungry and starving and
angry and then they sell out and now
they're on you know pop station but I
think all of us would sell out if we
could what if it comes down without
paycheck I boats that security get that
pain fence and you get to live the book
so you have way you break the fence and
you live in both
huh could be the crazy neighbor on the
bot that everyone yes looks the other
way zeneca light have the car that's
used as a garden what sort of things
well like with season one I feel like it
was I i wrote it very clean and when I
came into season two I added a little
more edge because I it it felt true and
honest to go a little more edge yeah
honestly that's what I felt and I feel
like that's what's hitting with people
whenever they read it so as far as I can
it's almost as like I would want this to
be on adult swim just like a 15 minute
little kind of edgy and you would never
expect something about someone being on
a track and field to be edgy because it
seems like such a clean you know people
just going there to run yeah but that's
the surprise of it yeah it's also you
know the same token though it's like the
one else it sound like it's like season
2 suddenly like super creepy and pervy
or anything no no it's not at all it's
just gotta pay until addiction oh yes
it's everything it's just more grown-up
it's a natural evolution and the best
way I can describe it it just it's
before I was into teenage years now it's
in its early 20s it's just growing up
and that's what happens and you know the
world's bigger you have to show over the
world so you know Harry Potter goes up
exactly potter harry potter does grow up
Nathan grows up they think Rosa
you